pologne ou fait nouvelle d'alès
valaisanne a interpellé ce matin à son
domicile par la milice atmosphère tendue
ce soir à agde ans après un début de
manifestation à la mémoire des victimes
de 70 empêchés par la police
la préparation des élections municipales
concession socialiste aux communistes
les primaires ne porterait plus que sur
onze villes beauté opposition accord
très large malgré quelques primaire les
oscars à l'exportation ou jean claude
killy couronné en tant que chef
d'entreprise
après l'erreur de traitement dans une
clinique de montauban qui a coûté la vie
à un jeune homme la responsabilité
médicale
de plus en plus souvent face à la
justice madame monsieur bonsoir le voile
de décembre est à nouveau tombé sur la
pologne en ce jour anniversaire des
émeutes sanglantes de 1977 dans ce qu on
apprenait ce matin que les valaisans qui
s'apprêtait à faire une allocution
publique cet après-midi les valises à a
été enlevé de son domicile had danse par
des miliciens en armes qui l'ont fait
monter dans une voiture pour une
destination inconnue là ce soir les
autorités de varsovie donnent leur
propre version des faits une version
ambiguë paul nahon
ces informations qui nous sont parvenues
il ya quelques instants à peine émane
des autorités polonaises ces autorités
affirment que monsieur lech walesa n'est
pas en état d'arrestation et qu'il se
trouve à l'heure actuelle dans un bureau
de contrôle des finances de la ville de
gdansk en effet toujours d'après le
gouvernement polonais la chambre suprême
de contrôle ayant découvert certaines
irrégularités financières a décidé de
convoquer aujourd'hui l'ancien leader de
solidarité pour qu'il fournisse des
informations et c'est en raison de son
refus de répondre à deux convocations
successives que monsieur lech walesa a
été conduit à ce bureau des finances
afin de s'expliquer après quoi il sera
libre et les autorités pollen polonaise
réaffirme que monsieur lech walesa est
tenu de respecter les lois en vigueur et
que ces lois sont les mêmes pour tous la
langue polonaise ne fait pas la
différence entre le
hermes interpellations et le terme
arrestation en tout cas cet après midi à
dans ce que la police se montrait en
force aux abords du monument aux
victimes des émeutes de 70 dans la
crainte que le rassemblement prévu et
auquel devait participer valaisanne ne
grossisse encore avec la nouvelle de son
interpellation
malgré l'intimidation policière quelques
centaines de personnes ont réussi à se
regrouper avant de se disperser dans le
calme
ce soir les images montrées par la
télévision polonaise donnait des
événements un aspect apparemment très
différent des faits philippe rochot
depuis l'aube la tension n'avait cessé
de monter dans la ville de gdansk autour
des chantiers lénine comme le montrent
ces images pourtant officielle de la
télévision polonaise la milice avec
blindés légers et canons à eau avaient
bloqué toutes les rues donnant accès au
monument à la mémoire des ouvriers
tombés lors des émeutes de 70 mais
l'hommage populaire était interdite la
milice redoutaient en effet de voir la
manifestation dégénéré en émeutes
plusieurs centaines de personnes avaient
pourtant réussi à se rassembler au pied
du monument en début d'après midi ils
ont été rapidement dispersés
c'est alors qu'un autre groupe de 200
manifestants apprenant l'arrestation de
lech walesa s'est rassemblée aux cris de
solidarité devant la poste centrale
cette fois les miliciens ont frappé et
interpellé plusieurs dizaines de
personnes interdisant aussi l'accès aux
journalistes en début de soirée la foule
se rassembler à nouveau mais cette fois
devant l'église sainte brigitte la
paroisse des chantiers navals pour une
messe du souvenir jean fred ou est-ce
que vous avez ce soir par vos contacts
des informations plus précises sur ce
qui se passe à gdansk et aussi sur le
sort de valises à mais tout à l'heure
j'ai réussi à obtenir quelqu'un varsovie
et on ne savait pas plus ce qu'elle
était le sort de balsa dans la capitale
des rumeurs circulaient comme quoi ils
n'étaient plus à gdansk il était arrivé
à varsovie et c'était un petit peu le
le bleu le plus total adam ce que même
on ne savait pas trop où on sait que
l'aïe était parti dans cette mercedes
noire ce matin mais pour quelle
destination c'était un petit peu
d'hésitation la plus totale alors est ce
que cette journée marque un nouveau
raidissement du régime vis-à-vis de la
situation à gdansk en particulier et
cela avant la suspension de l'état de
siège
je crois que l'on peut formuler quand
même deux hypothèses avec cette
arrestation de lech walesa
la première c'est que on peut dire bien
l'état de guerre est toujours en vie
dure puisqu'il n'est toujours pas
suspendu
officiellement seuls interviendra le 31
décembre et que donc dans cet état
aucune manifestation n'est autorisé les
cheveux les a avait donc manifesté le
désir de participer à cette cérémonie
aujourd'hui et d'y prendre la parole
on peut lui dire vous êtes en
contradiction avec la loi donc vous
n'avez pas le droit et on pratique une
mesure préventive il ya une deuxième
hypothèse peut-être plus politique mais
qui a une certaine je crois tonalité
quand même qu'il faut avoir à l'esprit
c'est le fait que la décision du général
jaruzelski de suspendre l'état de siège
provoque des remous au sein du parti
veut ouvriers polonais en particulier
chez les durs qui s'appuient en
l'occurrence sur les forces de sécurité
ont peut être voulu la faire un exemple
en disant général si vous voyez vous
mener une politique de petits pas
libéraux et voilà où cela mène tout de
suite on parle de manifestations en
conclusion il ya une chose qui me semble
important aujourd'hui c'est que les
valaisannes et vraiment pas un citoyen
libre comme tous les polonais et que
finalement c'est un symbole qui fait
quand même très peur au gouvernement
oui depuis un mois depuis sa libération
après onze mois d'internement
les valaisans avaient évité à gdansk eux
toute apparition publique ou toute
déclaration de nature à compliquer
officiellement ses rapports avec le
régime
cet après midi il aurait donc dû
prononcer une allocution dont le texte
avait été remis aux correspondants
occidentaux et qui était en fait un
appel à la patience et à la conciliation
michel str l'eau viciée walesa libre la
nouvelle fait immédiatement le tour du
pays
et des milliers de personnes attendent
le dirigeant syndical ce 13 novembre et
c'est la joie quand il arrive chez lui
dans les faubourgs ouvriers de gdansk la
joie mais aussi l'émotion et l'espoir
renaît d'une réconciliation nationale
pas à pas lech walesa c'est qu'il en est
un des principaux acteurs et il joue la
prudence
ils n'assistent pas le dimanche 21
novembre à cette messe en plein centre
de vie dans ce cas où des milliers de
ses partisans l'attendent
en vain c'est le lendemain de sa
rencontre avec monseigneur glemp le
primat de pologne
une rencontre symbole qui stoppe la
campagne de discrédit menée contre lui
mais qui surtout marque la continuité de
l'alliance entre le dirigeant de l'ex
syndicat solidarité et l'église fort de
ce soutien renouvelé
lech walesa que les autorités ne veulent
considérer que comme une personne privée
décide de faire entendre sa voix
publiquement c'est ce jour là lors d'un
pèlerinage à la vierge noire de
czestochowa que lech walesa annonce
qu'il donnera son avis sur l'évolution
de la société polonaise le 16 décembre
ce discours le voici communiqué à la
presse hier le ton les modérés mais
laisse valaisanne ne pourra le prononcer
comme prévu devant le monument aux
ouvriers morts dedans sq les événements
de pologne ont été suivis bien sûr toute
la journée avec attention et inquiétude
dans les capitales occidentales
à washington le président reagan a perdu
une occasion de se taire
il a annoncé publiquement cet après midi
la libération de valises à sur la base
d'une dépêche d'agencé qui n'avaient pas
été vérifiés
la maison blanche a dû ensuite faire
marche arrière tout en réaffirmant son
extrême préoccupation quant au sort de
l'ex-président de solidarité le vatican
a réagi avec prudence le pape n'a fait
aucune allusion au sort de valises à en
déjeunant avec des évêques français à
paris le sénat à l'exception de ses
membres communiste a observé une minute
de silence cet après midi avant que le
premier ministre pierre moreau
qui avec d'autres membres du
gouvernement venait répondre aux
questions des sénateurs
à voir donc pierre mauroy exprime son
indignation
je ne veux pas attendre davantage sans
vous exprimer mon sentiment
d'indignation personnel qui est celui du
gouvernement
lech walesa représente en pologne
le mouvement du peuple pour obtenir
davantage de droits davantage de liberté
davantage d'espoir
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs ne
n'arrête pas les droits
on n'arrête pas la liberté on n'arrête
pas l'espoir et le gouvernement français
et du côté des droits du côté de la
liberté et du côté de l'espoir une chape
de plomb est retombé sur la pologne a
dit ensuite le ministre des relations
extérieures claude cheysson qui a
déploré que la normalisation un peu
l'homme continue de s'inscrire dans les
limites très étroites de l'état de siège
les milieux politiques et syndicaux
à l'exception jusqu'ici du parti
communiste et de la cgt expriment de
leur côté leur indignation
l'émotion est vive dans la communauté
polonaise de paris en ce moment même une
cérémonie a lieu à l'église polonaise où
une plaque à la mémoire des victimes de
l'état de guerre doit être inaugurée
maurice werther vous êtes sur place et
ce qu'on y sent une émotion particulière
après cette journée mouvementée ici
c'est l'émotion et le recueillement dans
quelques instants
monseigneur bernad ski qui est le
recteur de la mission polonaise en
france va dévoiler une plaque je
l'écouté photons le terrible fiasco des
histories beaux gosses par guingamp nat
on tape leeds initiera à becache d'être
l'objet d'audiences tania wood du chien
avec tout juste inédit qui aborde ce
match et bières chaise banny cheveux
gris miniato egos de l'envié châu diop
et kendra douchez ges crise tout ça
parle en échec
et c'est donc sur l'hymne national
polonais que se clôt ce chapitre du
journal c'est tout ce que nous savons ce
soir donc sur le sort de valises à et
sur l'état de la rue à gdansk
retournons au sénat interrogé sur le
raidissement des rapports franco
algérien à la veille de la brève visite
à paris du président chadli
monsieur roy a précisé qu'une mission
irait à alger régler le dossier des
visas et des restrictions imposées par
la france à la venue des ressortissants
algériens un geste protocolaire mais
inhabituelle pour une visite de travail
et qui montre bien le prix que paris
attache aux relations avec l'algérie
le président mitterrand ira lui même
demain accueillir à l'aéroport le
président chadli qui est en ce moment à
bruxelles
en france l'actualité ce soir est
d'abord politique avec la préparation
des élections municipales qui continuent
d'agiter les états majors des partis
le groupe de travail commun ps pc doit
se réunir à nouveau demain pour trancher
définitivement en principe le cas des
villes dont socialistes et communistes
se disputent la tête de liste hier soir
le comité directeur du ps a décidé de
faire une concession au parti communiste
en ne retenant le principe de primaires
que dans 11 villes au lieu de 18
du côté de l'opposition après une
dernière réunion de concertation
aujourd'hui il semble bien que des
primaires n'interviendront que dans cinq
ou six villes philippe harrouard c'est
le point combien y aura-t-il de primaire
pc ps risquons un chiffre 11 11 villes
où le parti socialiste revendiquaient la
tête de liste à la place du maire
communiste sortant le comité directeur
du ps a établi cette liste
hier non sans difficulté liste qui sera
soumise dès demain matin à ses
partenaires communistes pour un accord
souhaité définir ces villes sont en
province
evreux nîmes race dieppe dans la région
parisienne
shell athis-mons gagny sevran
sartrouville poissy franck ont dit deux
remarques
au départ le litige portait sur 29
villes puis 10
ville on en est à 11 le parti socialiste
n'ira pas plus loin car il est vrai que
les socialistes ont cédé largement tout
à fait le sentiment que nous avons fait
des concessions parce que je voudrais
faire remarquer qu' on parle de 18
villes dans lequel il y avait il ya une
revendication du parti socialiste or on
parle de ville où le maire et
communistes il n'y a aucun cas de villes
dirigées par des socialistes ou les
communistes puissent revendiquer la tête
de liste ça prouve ir qui s'est quand
même passé quelque chose depuis deux ans
cela dit il y à des grincements de dents
au sein de fédérations socialistes par
exemple au moment où les élus
socialistes refusent l'arbitrage du
comité directeur qu'il est la tête de
lice au maire communiste sortant
deuxième remarque au parti communiste on
est plutôt satisfait mais on estime que
tout n'est pas réglé car le parti
communiste exclus des primaires dans
certaines villes qui ont été choisis par
les socialistes
je pense que nous progressons vers un
accord national
certes dans ce qu'on dit des travaux du
comité directeur du parti socialiste il
ya encore quelque chose qui nous importe
c'est que des villes où semble-t-il il
devrait encore y avoir aux yeux du parti
socialiste des primaires des villes dont
les critères d'appréciation donne un net
avantage au parti communiste des villes
comme nîmes comme sevran comme
sartrouville reste dans la leaf
du côté de l'opposition il y avait
également une réunion de concertation
entre udf et rpr
l'accord est large dit on mais il y aura
quelques primaires comme à lyon ou à
metz mais comme le faisait remarquer
bernard pons avec malice dans
l'opposition ces primaires on les
comptera sur les doigts d'une main
seulement politique encore avec un
sondage du quotidien le matin la cote de
popularité du chef de l'état a baissé de
6 points en un mois
48% des français jugent maintenant son
action positive 41% pensent le contraire
pour monsieur mauroy la baisse est un
peu moins sensible politique
présidentielle monsieur mitterrand a
effectué ce matin
visite surprise dans une usine près de
cherbourg lusine site alcatel qui fait
partie d'un groupe nouvellement
nationaliser la cge et qui est un
exemple de reconversion technologique
dans le domaine de la téléphonie
c'est la troisième fois que le chef de
l'état se rend ainsi inopinément sur le
terrain philippe celle ci elle songe n
31 en moyenne elles montrent des
commutateurs cette pièce des centraux
téléphoniques établi la liaison entre
les abonnés du téléphone
ici la grande majorité des travailleurs
près de 15 cents au total sont des
femmes qui viennent de vivre une
révolution technique sans licenciement
alors que la nouvelle technologie aurait
réclamé moins d'emplois le temps de
travail a été aménagé on peut choisir de
travailler 35 heures par semaine payées
37 ou bien au minimum 20 heures payées
23 avec également des solutions
intermédiaires
le président de la république a rappelé
que la diminution du temps de travail
doivent faire l'objet de négociations
sur les terrains et que la rigueur
n'était pas un objectif mais le moyen de
faire face à la crise
l'exemple de cette usine montre qu'il
est possible d'allier la performance
industrielle et le progrès social et de
réaliser des avancées technologiques
avec le maintien de l'emploi
bien entendu nous n'atteindrons pas ces
objectifs en un jour mais je ne veux pas
installé les français dans une austérité
permanente
je veux seulement que chacun fasse un
effort proportionné à ses moyens pour
que tout le monde s'en sorte
six visites sont une version moderne de
la tournée des popotes
elles permettent au président de la
république de prendre contact avec les
réalités économiques sociales humaines
loin des flonflons et des fastes des
voyages officiels fournis à françois
mitterrand l'occasion de souligner ses
préoccupations à cherbourg il a voulu
montrer que la diminution du temps de
travail était une solution au problème
de l'emploi à condition que l'entreprise
reste compétitive et que la preuve de
paye ne descende pas au dessous d'un
certain niveau
d'une façon générale ces visites coup de
poing illustre l'intérêt que le
président de la république manifeste
pour l'industrie la technologie de
pointe et les accords sociaux négocier
elles devraient se multiplier dans les
mois qui viennent la france va acheter
moins de pétrole à l'arabie saoudite le
contrat qui vient d'être renouvelé pour
trois ans ne représentent que la moitié
du contrat précédent 3 millions de
tonnes par an les économies d'énergie le
fléchissement de l'activité économique
mais aussi la volonté de diversifier nos
fournisseurs explique ce contrat plus
modestes le prix de principe reste fixé
à 34 dollars le baril c'est à dire le
prix que l'arabie saoudite va s'efforcer
de continuer d'imposer à ses partenaires
à la prochaine réunion de l'opep à
vienne dimanche prochain alors que le
marasme du marché pétrolier provoque une
guerre d
rabais entre les pays membres notons en
passant que dans l'annuaire des 5000
premières sociétés mondiales que vient
de publier l'hebdomadaire le nouvel
économiste pour l'année 82 ce sont deux
compagnies pétrolières qui reste en tête
l'américaine
exxon et la hollandaise shell
contrairement à l'an dernier il n'y a
plus d'entreprises françaises dans les
15 premières sociétés au tableau
d'honneur des bénéfices le meilleur
bénéfice français est réalisé par une
autre compagnie pétrolière elf aquitaine
les entreprises françaises les plus
performantes à l'exportation récompensé
aujourd'hui par le ministre du commerce
extérieur michel jobert qui a décerné
ses oscars dans la catégorie des
entreprises de moins de 500 employés
un lauréat aux noms célèbres qui fait la
preuve qu'un ancien champion sait
parfois se reconvertir
jean claude killy patron de l'entreprise
weleda qui fabrique des vêtements de ski
comme il se doit son portrait en jézabel
qu'ils ont faim de fans me and my swing
critiques qu'il a formulées par ces
magnifiques
c'est avec marc cormack que l'homme
d'affaires américain que jean claude
killy est devenu après les jeux
olympiques de 1968 l'un des meilleurs
supports de publicité aux états unis où
il est le sportif français le plus connu
avec marcel cerdan à cette époque où le
ski se développe en amérique du nord
qu'il y fait vendre aussi bien des
montres suisse des appareils de photo
japonais des cartes de crédit que des
bicyclettes
dix ans plus tard en 1978 jean claude
killy et son beau frère roger nicole
achète 50 % de l'entreprise de vêtements
de ski weleda cette année là le chiffre
d'affaires est de 13 millions de francs
dont 2
mignon à l'exportation il est
aujourd'hui de 75 millions dont 39
millions à l'exportation grâce entre
autres à la nouvelle ligne de vêtements
mais aussi à sa griffe jean-claude qu'il
s'est faite pour ces deux choses pour
une troisième qui est qui était la
constance de la qualité dans
dans les produits et surtout la
recherche de produits techniques
c'était extrêmement demandée depuis
cinq ou six ans à chaumont en vexin dans
la région parisienne ils sont
actuellement 330 a travaillé au succès
de l'entreprise ils étaient 115 il ya
cinq ans ces vêtements sont surtout
exporté en europe dans les pays alpins
bien entendu mais également au japon les
états unis et le canada constituant le
prochain objectif
un succès pratiquement garantie
difficultés dans les négociations
salariales l électricité et gaz de
france les cinq syndicats ont rejeté les
propositions de la direction à l'air
ratp les syndicats sont plus divisés
cinq syndicats ont voté pour et 5 contre
la décentralisation à l'oeuvre dans le
domaine de l'information ce soir à 19h20
au lieu des informations régionales
habituel qui couvrait la région provence
et corse
les corses ont eu droit à leur premier
journal télévisé insulaire désormais
quotidiens il traitera spécifiquement de
l'actualité de l'île son nom corsica
serre
soir ça y est nous y sommes vous venez
d'entendre le premier générique de la
première édition corti cazères quantique
hazera cela veut dire i cor ce soir le
journalisme en langue corse mais aussi
bien sûr en français après le statut
particulier pour la corse
un journal télévisé qui lui est donc
propre les corses attendait cela depuis
18 ans jusqu'à ce soir les actualités
corse étaient intégrés dans le journal
télévisé régional de mars heures jeux et
bien il est il est évident dans ce cadre
là il n'y a pas de doute que nous avons
à répondre à cette volonté d'expression
qui existent en corse et qui pèse très
lourd dans l'ensemble du problème corps
tel qu'on peut le percevoir ailleurs
cette volonté d'expression elle
s'exprime à tous les niveaux je dirais
bons comme dans les autres régions sur
les problèmes sociaux sur des problèmes
économiques mais peut-être plus que dans
d'autres régions encore sur un problème
culturel je dirais qu ici le problème
culturel pèsent extrêmement lourd dans
la vie et dans la volonté d'expression
et nous entendons y répondre en faisant
un journal qui qui intègre dans sa dans
sa présentation la langue corse
nous aurons un journal qui qui
présentera un certain nombre
d'informations aussi bien en langue
corse qu'en français et 100 m je leur
dis tout de suite sans mettre le corps
dans un ghetto avant dernière audience
aujourd'hui du procès de la sphère en
pin les avocats des inculpés ont
poursuivi leurs plaidoiries qui se
termineront demain matin le verdict doit
intervenir demain soir paul lefèvre à
cette heure si demain le verdict c'est à
dire la team conviction des cinq femmes
et sept hommes qui composent le jury de
la cour d'assises de paris
intime conviction de mots terribles car
elle signifie d'abord la justice humaine
qu'on appelle parfois populaire terrible
aussi ces deux mots car la loi
fondamentale précise qu'ils ne seront
pas motivés que les jurés n'ont pas à
rendre compte de leurs décisions
les peines demandées par l'avocat
général ne sont qu'une indication les
jurés peuvent fixer au dessus ou en
dessous
sur les huit accusés quatre ne sont que
des comparses qui en savent peut-être un
peu plus qu'ils le disent mais que l'
enquête a laissé sur le bord du talus
sur les quatre qui restent et qui sont
la cie
dès 20 ans et 15 ans demandé 2 10 on ne
sait rien de cette affaire et deux
autres répète d'accord pour de l'argent
on a accepté de garder un peu le baron
ou d'aller ramasser la rançon dans un
moment pareil
quelles que soient les convictions qu'on
puisse avoir il arrive toujours un
moment où on se dit mais s'il avait
raison
davantage quand on n'est pas juré c'est
qu'on peut attendre tranquillement que
d'autres tranches pour vous cette nuit
sur les douze jurés
il y en a certainement qui vont mal
dormir le tribunal de paris a mise en
délibéré son jugement dans la sphère du
docteur falck cet anesthésiste poursuivi
pour homicide involontaire après le
décès de trois jeunes femmes qu'il avait
endormie
hier on apprenait la mort dans une
clinique de montauban d'un jeune homme
atteint d'appendicite et qui victime
d'un arrêt cardiaque au moment de
l'anesthésique fut traitée à la zot au
lieu d'oxygène autant de drames qui
posent de plus en plus en france le
problème de la responsabilité médicale
face à la justice le dossier claude
crespo il y a 6 ans
madame nakai si à droite rentrer en
clinique pour un examen gynécologique
banal nécessitant une anesthésie locale
elle devait rester deux jours elle y
restera trois mois elle instaure 100%
handicapés
j'ai pu débuter fort comme je veux mais
je vis je crois que ça restera toujours
georges discuterons manic
il y avait une embolie gazeuse qui
s'était faite au niveau du cerveau
provoquer parfois provoquer bon il ne
savait pas exactement ils ont pas osé
dire le mot anesthésie aucune preuve
chaque année en france près de 1500
personnes meurent victimes des
complications imputé l anesthésie et ce
après une opération parfois bénis encore
d'un accident sur 741 estime pourtant
l'anesthésique tout comme la réanimation
est une vraie spécialité
alors où sont les problèmes il ya
d'abord les effectifs 5000 anesthésiste
pour quatre millions d'interventions
chaque année il ya surtout une question
de moyens tous les hôpitaux sont
théoriquement pourvu de c
trois lieux où se pratiquent
l'anesthésié avant l'intervention
pendant et après depuis une circulaire
de 1974
ces structures sont obligatoires
cependant il faut bien dire que elles ne
servent pas toujours pourquoi dans deux
dans deux conditions
d'une part elles ne sont pas forcément
ouverte 24 heures sur 24 et d'autre part
parfois si la structure existe on peut
ne pas s'en servir
pourquoi habituellement pour des raisons
de personnel la famille n'est qu'un
entame une procédure pour découvrir les
raisons de ce drame
elle a dû l'interrompre à la suite de
difficultés financières
mais comme elle de plus en plus de
français n'hésitent plus à recourir au
procès elle en justice est également le
moyen de connaître exactement ce qui
s'est passé car il faut reconnaître que
dans de nombreux cas le contact entre le
médecin et son malade ou la famille du
malade n'est pas suffisant et que
lorsqu'il ya un incident lorsqu'il se
produit une difficulté le médecin ne
disant rien ne voulons pas donner
l'explication le patient croit
volontiers qu'il ya une faute qui a été
commise et il désire savoir quelle est
cette faute et éventuellement savoir
dans quelle mesure elle peut être réparé
l'ancien gouvernement avait imaginé la
fonction de médiateur médical un relais
entre le corps médical et les usagers
cette idée a été abandonnée par les
dirigeants actuels
le monde de la formule 1 est en deuil le
constructeur britannique colline chapman
fondateur et président de la firme lotus
six fois championne du monde de formule
1 en course automobile est mort
aujourd'hui à l'âge de 54 ans une
information de dernière minute en
provenance de pologne responsables de
l'ex syndicat solidarité a été arrêté at
cette line à l'ouest du pays
une arrestation donc qui confirme le
raidissement des autorités de varsovie
il y avait un quarter aujourd'hui à
vincennes
vous voyez les résultats le 16 le 5 le 4
et le 14
les rapports pour 5 francs dans l'ordre
près de 166 mille francs dans un ordre
différent un peu moins de quatre minutes
maintenant le temps demain alain
gillot-pétré serait de voir votre
pochette comment je ne vois pas votre
pochette avait écouté les légions de
pour un peu de soleil et grise pour
beaucoup de nuages élevés sont frais
devant car il fera plus frais et il y
aura du vent un coup d'oeil sur la photo
satellite pour voir que ça ne s'arrange
vraiment pas avec eux tous ces nuages ci
qui vont devoir passer et on regarde la
carte parce qu'entre la faute aux séries
de la carte ça ne s'arrangera pas
davantage vous allez voir tout de suite
qu'une bande de pluie va traverser le
pays du nord ouest au sud est dans la
journée suivies de rafales de vent
accompagné de rafales de vent et suivies
de rafales de vent de nord ouest le ciel
deviendra variable sur le nord-ouest
frais avec encore des averses et
quelques rayons de soleil sur la
méditerranée il fera beau avant le
passage de cette zone de plus qui m me
dis-je futura de l'aquitaine à l'alsace
et pour le week-end pour samedi et
dimanche samedi variable et frais
dimanche de doux et pluvieux les
températures quant à elles sont en
baisse par rapport à aujourd'hui
nettement 3 4 5 degrés de moins il
faisait 21 degrés à perpignan ce match
cet après-midi le frac 14 demain minimum
7 degrés pour demain vendredi 17
décembre minutes de soleil en moins le
8h40 cochet 16 53 essais demain la
singine michael à 23h15 claude sérillon
vous présentera notre dernier journal
bonne soirée à demain 20 heures